[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans point
de vue vous connaissez la formule de
sujets brûlants d'actualité et deux
intervenants de talent pour en débattre
bonjour jérôme sainte marie bonjour vous
êtes politologues sondeurs président
fondateur du cabinet de conseil
d'expertisé de sondages pôle inbox est
votre dernier livre bloc contre bloc la
dynamique du maquereau nice n'a été
publié aux éditions du cerf et bonsoir
mathieu souquet vous êtes consultant
expert auprès de la fondation jean
jaurès et vous avez entre autres
activités était l'un des collaborateurs
de myriam el khomri la ministre du
travail
ii du quinquennat françois hollande
merci beaucoup on n'avait pas oublié
rassurez-vous vous avez d'ailleurs
publié au lieu de deux bilans avec les
plus et les moins du quinquennat de
france collants voile à la fondation
jean jaurès
premier thème du jour les écologistes
sont ils des amish les amish vous savez
si cette communauté américaine qui vit
comme au 19ème siècle comme la petite
maison dans la prairie pour faire court
pour les moins jeunes d'entre nous qui
se souviennent de ce feuilleton
inoubliable pourquoi est-ce qu'on se
pose cette question parce que c'est le
président de la république qui a choisi
d'en faire une punchline
emmanuel macron intervenait devant les
patrons de ce qu'on appelle la french
tech avec la tenue adéquate vous allez
voir et il a comparé les écologistes à
cette communauté traditionaliste pour
leur opposition à la 5 j'ai regardé la
france va prendre le tournant de la 5g
parce que c'est le tournant de
l'innovation et j'entends beaucoup de
voix qui s'élèvent pour nous expliquer
qu'il faudrait relever la complexité des
problèmes contemporains en revenant à la
lampe à huile
je ne crois pas au modèle amish et je ne
crois pas que le modèle amish permettent
de régler les défis de l'écologie
contemporaine
et l'expression n'est pas passé inaperçu
c'était probablement le but recherché
d'ailleurs je vous donne juste une
réaction mais on pourrait en trouver
beaucoup d'autres celle d' eric piolle
le maire europe ecologie les verts de
grenoble qui a qualifié les propos
présidentiels de totalement outrancier
et vous mettiez soutien vous partager ce
point de vue alors c'est en communiquant
c'est une punchline efficace puisque on
en parle de rond ne cesse même d'en
parler alors eric piolle il s'agit pas
de rendre hommage à eric piolle mais il
avait lu une formule qui m'avait paru
plus rigolote et qui ne faisait par
ailleurs insulte à aucune communauté
quand il avait critiqué la 5g en disant
qu'on n'avait pas forcément besoin
savoir le débit qui permettait de
regarder des films x dans l'ascenseur
voilà il avait une formule eux aussi
plutôt rigolote et qui encore une fois
n'était insultante pour meerson avait
des ports dire un peu plus j'ai police
et le commissaire terme pour le corps à
l'auditorat du figaro non on est là face
c'est toujours un peu dommage mais sans
doute que nous on aime ça on est là face
à deux procès donc il ya le procès de
l'écologie alors que là le président de
la république a décidé de faire en
pointant une entrée particulière pour
décrire ce qu'est l'écologie mais on a
en face c'est vrai aussi
le procès de la science on adore ça
alors le procès de la science est
beaucoup plus vieux je dirais même qu'il
est aussi vieux que la science mais ce
depuis toujours quoi est ce que vous
auriez signé vous cette tribune
deux instructions de responsables
écologistes 10 ans il faut un moratoire
sur la 5g parce que c'est une dame qui
peut être dangereuse s'il s'agit de
s'opposer aux progrès technologiques par
principe
c'est absurde s'il s'agit en revanche de
poser un certain nombre de questions
relevant d'éventuelles conséquences sur
l'environnement sur la santé humaine par
rapport à un progrès technologique
ça n'a rien d'absurde j'ajoute même que
les enchères sont lancées pour la 5g
soit par la 5g pardon à la fin du mois
et sont attendus pour les prochaines
semaines par ailleurs des expertises
complémentaires précisément pour affiner
autant que possible les expertises sur
les conséquences environnementales
encore une fois et sanitaires de la 5g
donc on aurait pu penser qu'ils étaient
rigoureux d'attendre les résultats de
ces expertises pour lancer les enchères
voilà et et une partie d'ailleurs de la
tribune qui a été publié dans le jdd ce
week end relève de cela de cette logique
la pointe en fait cette défaillance tas
s'il s'agit encore une fois de s'opposer
à la 5g par principe ça c'est absurde et
je crois que même chez les écolos
personne ne le fait c'est pas le sujet
jérôme sainte marie
oui alors c'est un manuel da cruz là se
trouve dans son écosystème si je veux
dire c'est à dire il est dans le monde
de la french tech les vous souvenez est
vain mot et qui l'a d'ailleurs répété à
peu près 127 x discours c'était dans le
système
voilà c'est quand même dans le même
milieux peut-être un peu permissif pour
lui qu'il avait eu cette phrase vous
savez c'est la station f
il avait ni dans une gare puisque
c'était censé être une gêne dans cette
gare il avait opposé ceux qui
réussissent et ceux qui ne sont rien
n'avait pas fait beaucoup de bien et là
l'appel trail c'est vrai qu'on en parle
mais il prend un point de vue qui est
ouvertement caricatural alors par
ailleurs vous avez face il ya peut-être
que tout le monde l'a déjà dit mais j'ai
pas j'ai peint finalement rien de la
presse et aujourd'hui je pense que vous
devez penser au général de gaulle vous
savez nous n'allons pas le vide vous
souvenez c'était leur était le temps de
la marine à voile le 14 juin 1960 le
général de gaulle dit il est tout à fait
naturel qu'on ressent sa nostalgie de ce
qu'ils étaient l'an pire puisqu'il en
train de vendre français en fait la
décolonisation de l'afrique noire
tout comme on peut regretter la douceur
des lampes à huile la splendeur de la
marine à voile
là le charme du temps des équipages mais
quoi il n'y a pas de politique qui
vaille en dehors des réalités et donc
moi ça m'a intéressé parce qu'au fond
avec une formule qui n'a rien à voir
avec le sujet il s'agissait la
décolonisation de l'afrique noire à
laquelle français étaient relativement
peu attaché mais juste derrière il y
avait l'algérie qui poser davantage de
problèmes
et au nom d'une espèce d'idéologie du
changement récupéré par le grand
modernisateur finalement qui a été le
général de gaulle ont fait passer des
choses qui par un pur professeur
rhétorique c'est le court comme on irait
chez le sens de l'histoire
comme on a vendu en 92 l'europe français
le monde et unique le marché unique en
disant c'est le sens de l'histoire
moi ça m'inquiète un petit peu des cons
légitime quelque chose précisément par
le sens de l'histoire pour prendre un
autre personnage apprécié au figaro il
était chroniqueur et éditorialiste
raymond aron je me rappelle une émission
au raymond aron s'était fortement
opposée à quelqu'un qui lui parlait du
sens de l'histoire je préfère c'est un
écologiste en dix ans mais moi qui la
fin de son existence moi j'ai connu
toutes sortes de période où la modernité
et le sens de l'histoire c'était des
choses abominables qui n'ont d'ailleurs
pas durer et donc c'est moi celui la
rhétorique foulée de la modernité pour
elle même me laisse toujours un peu
sceptique je vais déplaire à jérôme
quand même mais on observe qu'il y a un
sens de l'histoire en ce moment et qui
aujourd'hui fait à peu près consensus
c'est que si on continue sur les
logiques qui sont les nôtres depuis
plusieurs décennies la nature va
s'autodétruire tag la catastrophe
écologique est garanti il y a quand même
un en déplaise à donald trump qui là
encore faisait des déclarations il ya
quelques jours assez assez loufoque
il y à un consensus scientifique autour
du fait que les logiques industrielles
et économiques qui sont les nôtres
produisent de la destruction de
l'environnement est que pour la première
fois nous pourrons être en situation en
fait on ne nous autodétruire par les
choix d'organisation collective qui sont
les nôtres donc le sens de l'histoire
ou en tout cas l'inflexion de l'histoire
qui correspond à al alerte que les
écologistes tirent depuis un demi siècle
il ya un demi siècle il était danseur
dallaire et on les prenait pour des
hurluberlus aujourd'hui en réalité même
si beaucoup critiquent les écologistes
l'écologie comme courants de pensée
s'est imposée ce n'est pas d'hier que
tout le monde en fait ne veut pas dire
que l'écologie est uniforme
il ya de la croissance alternative mais
il ya aussi de la décroissance on peut
envisager les choses différemment
ce qui est sûr c'est que l'écologie a en
quelque sorte gagné la bataille
culturelle
plus personne aujourd'hui noz quand même
revendiquer une action qui aille contre
des principes de l'écologie
là il ya quand même une affection du
lala gagné la bataille culturelle mais
pour en revenir à la 5g vous pensé quand
la 5g sera déployé les les français ils
renonceront en disant c'est pas écolo
alors nous la laissions des mêmes et
même je dirais que c'est un débat tout à
fait intéressant que de poser la
question du numérique et de l'écologie
est ce que pour devrait basculer dans ce
qu'on appelle de ce que dans ce que
daniel cohen a appelé le capitalisme
numérique
ça nous fait régresser en matière
environnementale la plupart des experts
me disent plutôt le contraire sortir du
capitalisme industriel et de nos
économies carbonées pour aller vers un
capitalisme numérique est a priori bon
l'environnement alors encore une fois il
faut prendre énormément de précautions
avec cela mais on a vu que déjà pour
reprendre l'actualité récente
le confinement la vie du monde entier en
confinement n'a pas été un effondrement
grâce au numérique le numérique a été un
élément de notre survie collective tout
à fait déterminant et grâce au numérique
on a pu vivre et faire un exercice de
décroissance grandeur nature on a arrêté
polluent la planète
on a supprimé un certain nombre
d'activités qu'on jules est tout à fait
inopérante et la question est de savoir
si dans le monde d'après le numérique
est une arme tout à fait décisive pour
créer un environnement qui soit plus
propre qu'il n'a été alors précisément
un mathieu soutière parce que quand je
le critique cet argument du changement
inéluctable du sens de l'histoire de la
modernité prises pour elle même
c'est qu'effectivement ça ne résout pas
les débats prenons les exemples que vous
avez pris donc le problème de l'écologie
qui est largement un problème
énergétique et bien dire
qu'effectivement il ya un réchauffement
climatique
il ya sans doute très probablement même
le un impact de l'offre qu'on parle de
l'anthropocène maintenant est ce pas
voilà donc un impact de l'homme sur son
environnement que catastrophique cédera
très bien mais on en tire quelle
conclusion qu'il faut importer des
éoliennes de chine bien qu'il faut
maintenir et développer notre industrie
nucléaire
oui c'est vrai ce mois ci un vrai débat
qui avait les mêmes motivations
écologiques nous donne d un avenir tout
à fait il ya tout à fait différent donc
et par ailleurs effectivement lorient
nous serons d'accord je crois cette
question de la 5g pour autant que j'ai
pu comprendre tous les enjeux pose des
questions qui sont pas simples est-ce
que effectivement ce va avoir 1 apporte
par rapport à l'écologie extrêmement
positif
c'est assez probable si ça permet toute
sorte d'éviter des déplacements
ça permet aux gens de travailler de
vivre encore plus qu'un parent
confinement encore plus chez eux en
province
ça peut être pas mal on n'est pas obligé
de s'agglutiner dans les métropoles
ça peut être un facilitateur pour cela
mais comme souvent en matière d'écologie
il ya un couffin et secousses et
notamment celui des libertés parce que
là sur la 5g
il semblerait quand même si j'ai bien
compris le dossier que on va avoir
on va donner on va numériser en quelque
sorte des informations de manière encore
plus abondante et encore plus
centralisée qu autrefois à tenir
convenablement
on pourra tout savoir de notre activité
minute par minute pour assise avec les
objets connectés et cetera
là on arrive dans un schéma hyper
reliance il faut se dire où on est
comment dirais-je totalement transparent
notre vie peut être totalement
transparente à des gens qui nous
surveillent ray or comme par ailleurs
les gens nous surveille c'est pas la
paranoïa et de données partout aux états
unis et c'est quand qu'on s'intéresse à
la guerre économique notamment on voit
quel usage pour en être fait c'est un
sujet de préoccupation
je dis pas que je contre en plus un mais
des sujets jeunes et les réactions de
nos internautes si vous voulez bien
qu'ils réagissent à la fois sur twitter
et sur lefigaro.fr degré considère que
les écologistes sont pas des amis parce
que les à messieurs sont pour un mode de
vie à l'écart des autres sans
technologie alors que les écolos sont
pour un mode de vie soucieux de
l'environnement
sur youtube inconnu nous dit on peut
être contre la 5g ne pas être écolo
c'est mon cas philippe sur youtube
toujours qu'il nous dise si le président
commence par des injures et du mépris
ce débat est mal parti et il ya mike
aussi qu'il nous dit on n'a pas besoin
de la 5g la 4g est déjà largement
suffisante pour nos usages actuels
d'envoyer c'est assez partagés et notre
petit sondage sur twitter les écolos
anti 5g peuvent-ils être comparé à des
amish bien c'est non à 55 % donc donc en
fait ce procès en quelque sorte un refus
de la modernité fait aux écolos il
semble être un peu à peu rejetés par nos
internautes et par ailleurs je ne sais
pas dans quelle mesure cela contretemps
mais il est vrai que là le comment le
choix tactiques de la reine est parti
présidentiel fait pour les municipales
était d'aller au combat électoral contre
les écolos il n'y a eu aucune alliance
entre l'arrêt mais les écolos ce qui dit
qu' apparemment cette alliance est
contre nature
voilà si elle avait pu le sort qu est ce
très quelque part ça aurait été le cas
ça n'a pas été le cas
le choix encore une fois de la majorité
présidentielle était et est allé d'être
allé pardon au combat électoral contre
les écolos il en remet la une pastille
en critiquant frontalement effectivement
les écolos alors même que quand même je
ne sais pas si on peut parler de l'algue
verte
mais on a tous en tête que les grandes
métropoles françaises ont basculé chez
les verts et on sait que précisément
c'est dans les grandes métropoles que
les problématiques écolo
environnementales sont les plus aigus en
matière de congestion urbaine de
transport etc
voilà donc je je je ne sais pas dans
quelle mesure émana qu'on n'est pas un
peu à contre courant alors qu'on
l'attend quand même dans les deux années
qui le séparent de l'élection
présidentielle sur ces sujets-là a
fortiori après encore une fois la
conférence citoyenne sur le climat qui
faisaient du moratoire sur la 5g l'une
de ses 150 propositions
j'appuierai la vallée les propos de je
maintiens soupière par en référence à un
article qui est paru à la fondation jean
jaurès par votre camarade jean le final
stein sur ce qu'il appelle le bloc je
crois écolo scalzo sociale et colons
social écolo et donc pas sur ça vraiment
un bloc n'est un bloc très durable mais
par contre si effectivement il souligne
la proximité politique désormais entre
les écologistes et la gauche et les
socialistes notamment ce qui était moins
le cas face c'était le cas au départ
c'était moins le cas ensuite que de
nouveaux sont multiples le cas et ça
peut être un risque que malgré tout pour
emmanuel macron c'est donc c'est vrai
que la brutalité de son propos je
voudrais insister surtout pas ce qui va
frapper en l'écoutant c'est à quel point
c'est de nouveau un procédé de
disqualification de l'adversaire et vous
savez c'est le beau dangers du
progressisme toutefois manier d'ailleurs
par pas manier le maquereau ou même
autrefois c'est à dire on a comment
dirais-je
on a le progrès justement donc le sens
de l'histoire et c'est pour nous les
lumières contre l'obscurité et donc qui
n'est pas progressiste et populistes se
souvenir c'est même trop poli je crois
dans leur bouche donc populiste
nationaliste conservateur etc c'est des
êtres voilà c'est exactement et prompte
à dire la foule haineuse donc et vous
avez donc et l'a de nouveau sur un autre
tableau sur un autre théâtre on a cette
disqualification où grosso modo l'a dit
ils auraient dit les gens qui sont
contre à 5 g sont des ringards et de
l'abruti le sens et faire un référendum
sur l'a5 gère pour tous est un sujet
très grand public demandé aux français
ce qu'ils en pensent
ce sera une bonne idée encore une fois
toute initiative qui se fonde sur de la
participation citoyenne je pense qu'on
peut être pour au niveau local ça se
pratique depuis des années et des années
je pense quand même que le grand débat
le débat national qui a fait suite au
mouvement de gilet jaune était une
initiative intéressante je ne juge pas
des conséquences politiques donné à cela
mais le fait de dire au peuple
vous avez la parole expliquez-nous quels
sont vos préoccupations c'est important
et la conférence citoyenne sur le
climat- de ce point de vue là constitue
là encore une initiative intéressante
donc pourquoi pas un déchet technique en
revanche les soupières gmail d'un
terreau est ce que pour la convention
citoyenne pour le climat 1849
propositions parmi ces propositions il y
avait le moratoire je crois et le débat
sur la 5g
or emmanuel macron a dit sûr de ses 149
proposition peu les retient tout sauf
3.2 cas où la guitare de man il a trois
que je ne retiens pas laissant
implicitement comprendre que les 146
autres étaient quasi adoptée était quasi
adopté en tout cas que les entériner or
les trois qu'une proposition ce n'est
plus en tête à vrai dire mais ces trois
propositions qui ne lui plaisait pas
les feux de la saint jean ne faisait pas
partie so lu ment donc seulement il peut
y avoir sur des gens qui ont sont
intéressés qu'on jouait les jeux si vous
voulez mais cette convention citoyenne
pour le climat donc on peut parfaitement
critiqué son principe d'ailleurs mais en
tout cas mon set est organisée validé
par l'état validé par le présent la
république et là tout d'un coup il se
contredit
il se contredit et avec une forme de
précipitation mathieu soupière à
souligner tout à l'heure le 29 septembre
c'est l'attribution des fréquences je
crois et ont rappelé à un gros opérateur
la star et sa dépression déployer les
bleus on est pas très en avance et
puisque personne ne me demande mon avis
je vais le donner
moi je trouve plus maniema qu'on a bien
fait ne pas suivre les qu'on vend les
recommandations de cette fleuriste et
une voyelle qui n'est ni une convention
ni citoyenne parce que la vérité c'est
qu'on a demandé à des milliers de gens
s'ils voulaient en faire partie et seuls
les militants écologistes ont répondu
oui parce que les autres avait autre
chose à faire non est le résultat des
courses c'est un programme que je trouve
pour ma part assez maximaliste mais ça
n'est qu'un jeu vous donne celui
d'anthony aussi qui nous dit que
personne est obligée d'utiliser à 5 g
après tout ça j'en suis pas sûr parce
que ce qu'on va pouvoir garder ses
anciens on a on a quand même un sujet on
sait que compte tenu de l'augmentation
en particulier des consommations
l'augmentation de l'explosion de
l'augmentation exponentielle des
communications dans quelques années les
réseaux de la 4g seront saturées ils
sont par ailleurs énergivore donc se
pose véritablement la question de
comment faire avaler par ailleurs on
sait que la 5g porte un débit qui
offrira de nouvelles fonctionnalités
qu'on ne sait même pas aujourd'hui
totalement envisagé et qui pour ce qui
est de ce qu'on appelle la ville
intelligente et la ville intelligente
c'est une ville aussi plus écolo est
tout à fait déterminant et d'ailleurs
ainsi 2,2 de points de vue qui vous
conforte
dans ce sur ce sujet et celui d'anthony
qui nous dit j'utilise la 5g depuis six
mois dans le cadre de mon travail et
c'est loin d'être un gadget et puis
exquis sur youtube nous dit il ya des
applications pratiques à la 5g par
exemple pour les opérations
chirurgicales à distance effectivement
d'aider des manoeuvres qui demande
beaucoup des changes de données et puis
on laisse le dernier mot année qu'autre
chose sur youtube il ya beaucoup de
réactions pardon aux internautes que je
ne cite pas je pense que la modernité
peut apporter beaucoup à l'écologie
c'est presque un sujet de discussion
philosophie un complément quand même
juste sur ce discours il est très
maladroit le 13 avril
emmanuel macron prenons fait de la
situation
c'est à dire une crise sanitaire qui
bloque l'économie mondiale dit que nous
avons à réinventer notre modèle de
développement que nous avons à nous
réinventer les uns et les autres à
redonner du sens encore une fois à notre
organisation collective on voit que la
menace sanitaire et la menace
environnementale pèse fort et donc
derrière en fait faire un discours aussi
ras des pâquerettes et effectivement
dans le style d'un circulez ya rien à
voir
bar est un peu court je n'avais pas
trouvé de lien entre les deux sujets du
jour mais finalement jérôme sainte marie
c'est vous qui l'avez trouvée puisque
maintenant on va parler de de ce cas
assez extraordinaire d'un père qui était
devenue une femme et qui du coup vous
voulez être considérée comme étant la
mère de sa fille ça est un peu complexe
et va y revenir mais c'est peut-être le
sens de l'histoire celui dont vous
parliez c'est à dire le fait qu'il n'y
ait plus de 2 norme définitive y compris
quand on est un père et une mère c'est
peut-être ça aussi la modernité le sujet
je vous le résume en quelques phrases la
cour de cassation vient de refuser la
demande d'une personne qui demandait à
être reconnue comme la mère de sa fille
il se trouve que cette personne est une
transsexuelle et elle était donc avant
un homme et quand elle était un homme
elle a eu sept enfants elle est devenue
une femme et donc elle demande à être la
mère et la cour de cassation dit non
vous pouvez être le père ou le parent
biologique mais mais pas la mer alors
c'est un sujet tellement compliqué quand
c'est pas très bien comment l'aborder
donc là toute façon la plus simple si je
dirais qu est ce que vous pensez est ce
que ça va trop loin ou est ce que c'est
une demande qui était légitime jérôme
sainte marie
alors ce qui est bien avec les
changements de mentalité qui sont très
rapides dans le domaine des moeurs et
que le point de vue qu'on avait il ya
vingt ans et plus plus compréhensible
pour ses propres enfants en quelque
sorte voyez ce que je veux dire c'est à
dire que la l'évolution est extrêmement
rapide sur ces questions là et il ya eu
autrefois il y avait plein de mal de
gens qui ont écrit des bouquins de coups
notamment dans les milieux qui sont les
plus favorables dans le milieu des
sciences sociales et milieu de la
psychologie mais la psychanalyse dans
ces milieux sont souvent les plus
favorables aux par mon image par
tendances socio culturel disons à toutes
ces transformations était ont écrit
plein de bouquins sur le rôle du père le
rôle de la mère les traumatismes fédéral
mais la mémoire tout ça je sais pas si
c'est une théorie était vraiment faim
ils ont existé et c'était le sens commun
il ya 20 ans là le fait de même si on
commençait et danse avance si on
commence évolution jeu pas sur mais
voilà comment la comment si on
commençait à défendre ses points de vue
là souvent par rapport à des gens corps
et 25 ans aujourd'hui c'est même pas
qu'on serait combattue
on se reprend m'ont traitée de fasciste
parce que ça cela c'est la tendance mais
surtout on n'aurait pas compris je crois
ça qui est assez c'est ça qui est est
assez assez remarquable et mais là
effectivement pour stocker le rapport
entre les deux sujettes à ces grands
c'est à dire que ses rangs le
progressisme dans toute sa splendeur à
la fois et là je vais citer mon auteur
favori c'est à dire jean claude fischer
quand ils rappellent effectivement cette
le culte du progrès et les dégâts que ça
assez pour la gauche d'ailleurs qu'un
bouquin qui est là d'ssus le mythe
d'orphée je crois le complexe d'orphée
pardon et demie cher il montre bien
d'ailleurs le rapprochement inéluctable
du libéralisme culturel et le
libéralisme économique
est on est on vit dans un espèce de
climat généralisé d'obsolescence
programmée
c'est l'obsolescence programmée vous
voyez on pas de laquelle j'ai à la 5g on
change on est sommé de changer de
téléphone de la saga la ligue mais aussi
sous les 6 mois et là on a effectivement
une obsolescence programmée les cadres
familiaux des cadres moreau
traditionnelle à la place de leurs
directs alors ce que j'en pense mais je
crois que chacun aura compris alors les
magistrats de la cour de cassation
qu'est ce que vous auriez dit alors et
demande ça m'arrange je ne suis pas
magistrat on voit bien que c'est une
question complexe parce qu'elle mêle une
dimension de d'organisation collective
de vie sociale de principes très
généraux est une question très intimes
est une question très intime alors je
parlerai pas de progressis ou même de
sens de la modernité
il y a néanmoins un sens de l'histoire
qui fait qu'on s'est globalement
affranchi de domination une première qui
était celle de la nature l'histoire de
la vie humaine en collectivité
globalement avant on était dominée par
la nature ont tous deux soumis à des
logiques naturel qui nous dépassait on
s'est progressivement a franchi tous tas
et puis le deuxième la deuxième chape
qui pesait sur nous elles étaient
d'ordre moral culturel
elle relevait de la religion et le poids
de la religion on s'est affranchi en
fait de ceux de ces deux dimensions est
d'ailleurs bien souvent n'a pas bien
souvent mais les deux étaient à l'époque
intrinsèquement lié l'ordre naturel et
l'ordre divin était considéré comme tout
à fait semblable on s'est affranchi tout
cela est et je veux dire c'est très
concret on va donc très bien avant alors
est ce que c'est bien jeu dans ce cas de
figure est ce que on s'est affranchie
d'un certain nombre de choses avant où
on se mariait on se mariait pour pour
respecter les règles du milieu social
dont on était issue on choisissait pas
son mari on choisissait pas sa femme
je veux qu'on passe et plus de l'analyse
cui plutôt que du point de vue est-ce
que vous pensez que c'est un progrès de
dire que si un père a changé de sexe il
peut être connue comme la mère de son
enfant on a avancé en tout cas sur le
chemin de la société du choix du choix
individuel et la question est de savoir
comment on dirait qu'on n'est pas
complet si si si si je vais vous
répondre
on a avancé encore une fois sur dans la
société du choix sur le chemin de la
société du choix où l'individu de
plus en plus et mis en situation de
pouvoir faire un choix
un choix qui correspond à sa volonté à
ses attentes dès lors qu'on offre à
l'individu dès lors qu'on offre à
l'individu la possibilité encore une
fois de faire valoir un droit un droit
nouveau qui encore une fois fait écho à
sa volonté intime et que ce droit
nouveau ne fait de tort à personne
pourquoi ne pas considérer qu'il s'agit
là d'un progrès c'est une réponse claire
jérôme sainte-marie ça fait de tort à
personne parce que pour l'ancien
champion stabiliser changement de
société font du tort aux jo vous voyez
ce que je veux dire on vous avez
également le cas de la gpa lettre la
question effectivement de créer un
marché de l'enfant
je crois que moi mais un salon qui s'est
tenue il ya pas longtemps un porte de
champerret ça fait du tort à sa fait du
tort à dijon c'est pas parce que c'est
on bascule notamment à gauche dans une
d2 logis là-dessus qui est hyper libéral
parce qu'on a trouvé deux personnes pour
signer un contrat ensemble que ça fait
du tort à personne ça vous avez
effectivement une exploitation pour vous
voir une exploitation du corps etc et
une société a le droit d'avoir des
normes morales on le voit sur la
question de la prostitution voile sur la
question du travail des enfants et c'est
tout ce qui est possible et même si
c'est accepté par les personnes en
quelque sorte que la prostitution c'est
aussi un contrat si on gagne on y
réfléchit et bien c'est ça peut être
considéré pour une morale supérieure
comme quelque chose qui n'est pas qu'il
n'est pas bon par ailleurs ces questions
de morale c'est pas tout à fait vrai que
l'évolution est inéluctable il ya des
pays et je pense qu'ils comprennent des
pays musulmans par exemple ou la roue
s'est mis à fonctionner a tourné à
l'envers on peut trouver ça on peut
trouver ça tout à fait détestable et
partitions à côté c'est effectivement
pas très sympathique mais vous avez par
exemple la révolution iranienne
à la fin des années 70 se produit aussi
parce que le processus de modernisation
notamment en matière de moeurs et s'est
voulue par le shah d'iran heurte une
population qui n'en veut pas géré c'est
comme ça il n'y a pas de complot
là-dedans révolution conservatrice alors
qui va assez loin effectivement et on
constate ça également dans d'autres dans
d'autres domaines vu qu'actuellement
d'après le sondage toujours fonction
changera et ipsos
là on a une progression très forte des
gens qui sont favorables au
rétablissement de la peine de mort moi
personnellement je suis pas favorable
donc mais en tout cas ça prouve bien
qu'il n'y a pas de deuxième voire non
loin d'elle on ne m'attend pas quand
vous dites à coup c'est vous pensez bien
à cela donc voilà dix ans que jean
foulée
et pour ça qu'ils pour ça que c'est vous
évolution là puisque vous nous donner un
jugement de valeur voulait bien compris
qu'il sera négatif par rapport à ces
évolutions là je crois que la clé de ce
si c'est pas une question comment
dirais-je de sens de l'histoire et
inéquitable de ses marges en fait j'en
ai une lecture qui est toujours un peu
la même c'est tout ça et remy a exprimé
par un type sap l'écart marche contre
est plus à gauche désormais mais
heureusement vous en êtes un enfant d'un
plu à dire à droite qu'à gauche les
carmarks notamment dans le manifeste du
parti communiste donc c'est un cri en
1850 47 pardon et publié je pense en
février 48 ans lui est donc un très bon
ici nous appelle le jaune qui remarque
d'ailleurs que donc conseil très
intéressant et bien là dessus il ya des
phrases très précises sur justement le
fait que le développement du système
capitaliste qui à l'époque en plus c'est
pas contre marck l'écrit est encore une
société traditionnelle qui existent dans
toute l'europe avec une morale
chrétienne qui est bien fort qui est
forte la lui dis tout cela
le désenchantement du monde en quelque
sorte ça va être le fait non pas des
révolutionnaires ou des as t il à être
l'effet plus précisément du capitalisme
lui même qui détruira qui noiera vous
savez dans les eaux glacées du calcul
égoïste c'est sa formule toutes les
illusions morale etc et ce processus
révolutionnaire du capitalisme on a sous
les yeux
on l'a sous les yeux ça s'accélère même
je suis pas sûr que ce soit un progrès
humain c'est un progrès économique il
dit si vous n'êtes que c'est un progrès
humain vous ne vous disiez vous même que
les mentalités évoluent et de façon très
rapide et mêmes de façon accélérée c'est
c'est tellement vrai le comment le
procès en eugénisme on le fait en fait
depuis que le débat sur l'interruption
volontaire de grossesse existe alors on
reviendra peut-être un jour en arrière
en supprimant l'interruption volontaire
de grossesse mais aujourd'hui c'est un
fait acquis au moment où la loi est
votée en 74
la majorité des français y est opposée
52% des français y sont opposés
aujourd'hui l'immense majorité des
français est favorable à liv et j'ai
quelques années après débat sur
l'homosexualité et la dépénalisation de
l'homosexualité à l'époque des débats
quasi hystérique et en 86 mitterrand est
à l'elysée depuis cinq ans moi même j'ai
13 ans en 86 un quart des français
pensent que l'homosexualité est une
maladie mans
une maladie mentale on voit bien
qu'aujourd'hui
l'homosexualité est quelque chose de
totalement admis alors certaines
personnes peut-être je ne sais pas ce
qu'elle paie statistiquement pense que
tous les maux de l'époque sont peut être
liés en particulier à la reconnaissance
de l'homosexualité mais globalement on
va donc les mentalités évoluent et de ce
point de vue là me semble-t-il de façon
plutôt progressiste et consensuellement
progressif consensuellement progressive
je vous donne les points de vue de nos
internautes vous êtes nombreux à réagir
sur youtube c'est très bien comme ça
alors il ya une question de yann qui
nous dit et pour l'état civil ça se
passe comment cette affaire est bien
cherian c'est justement l'objet de la
requête du père c'est que la justice
avait admis qu' il pouvait y avoir la
mention de parents biologiques ou deux
paires sur l'état civil mais pas celle
de mer et c'est donc cette décision qu'a
confirmé la cour de cassation
notre sondage twitter qui n'est pas un
sondage puisque vous vous vous prenez
position librement sans qu'ils aient
d'histoire de d'échantillons
représentatifs
un père transsexuel peut-il être
reconnue comme la mère de son enfant
vous considérez que non à 76% et il y à
diverses réflexions celle de gama qui
nous dit est ce qu'une voiture peut être
reconnu comme un train point
d'exclamation ou d'interrogation otaku
je n'ose imaginer les séquelles pour
l'enfant et que c'est assez d'accord
d'ailleurs et ajoute ce choix individuel
peut avoir de graves conséquences
psychologiques pour l'enfant et puis il
ya cette réalité décrite par jojo il ne
peut tout simplement pas être la mère
car son enfant a déjà une mère et c'est
vrai que biologiquement cet homme n'est
pas la mère de cet enfant puisqu'il
n'avait pas encore été opéré pour être
les choses un peu crûment et que donc
c'est en étant sexuellement un homme
qu'il a eu sept enfants mais on s'est
affranchi là aussi encore une fois de
des règles de la biologie donc on peut à
chaque fois vouloir s'y soumettre ou est
il être ramenés mais je fais café du
commerce
je me prénomme mathieu si demain en fait
je décide que j'ai envie qu'on m'appelle
mathilde les gens trouveront ça un peu
farfelue mais après tout qui ça dérange
et puis le quelques quelques temps après
je décide que non seulement je m'appelle
mathilde mais que je me sens femme
j'ai tous les attributs d'un homme
bon je vais pas vous le montrer ici mais
j'ai a priori tous les attributs d'un
homme mais ne tentez pas m'aimer mais et
alors je me sens femme
où est le problème où est le problème la
biologie ne dis pas que je suis une
femme mais six mois en conscience car un
train ou un camion n'a pas de conscience
oui mais un être humain on a eu six mois
en question cette semaine sans femme et
je me revendique pas logiquement
troublant pour pour votre enfant elle y
pose poser des difficultés pour se
situer alors on a longtemps considéré
que des parents qu'ils divorçaient
c'était source d'un traumatisme très
puissant chez les enfants il ya le coût
de ces quelques pour enfants qui vous le
confirme alors mais il ya aussi beaucoup
de psychologues pour enfants il
s'intéresse au cas d'enfants de parents
mariés est encore en couple et qui ont
aussi des difficultés voilà mais pendant
très longtemps
le divorce était interdite puis le
divorce a été autorisée est aujourd'hui
encore une fois il ne semble pas pardon
mais nous ne disposons pas d'études
médicales d'études scientifiques qui
disent que les enfants de parents
divorcés à conditions égales
encore une fois souffre de davantage de
traumatisme
donc les enfants de parents ont couple
donc cette aventure je suis assez tard
sûrement d'accord en tout cas là dessus
certaines voix un peu dans ce sens mais
bon c'est vrai je suis frappé par un fan
cuevas est valide complètement cette
histoire de libéralisme culturel moment
très fort très très fort à gauche et
qu'un homme à gauche a d'ailleurs aucun
cas puisque globalement la matière
visant les françaises se détend de
régulation sociétale cette idée que une
société de choix serait meilleur une
société où on aurait on aurait moins
c'est une notion qui est tout à fait
contestable c'est vrai là parce que on
peut pas raisonner comme des nerfs comme
une forme de robinsonnades où chacun
résonne comme individu si j'ai envie de
sénat non vie en société et c'est pas
qu'on vit en société c'est pas la
société par un cadre extérieur à nous
c'est la société qui nous fait si on est
en train de débattre et ce qu'on a
appris à parler français qu'on a un vrai
qu'on a fait des choses et c'est vrai
qu'on a appris très bonne chose et ça
c'est pas nous qui l'avons décidé et
c'est la société qui ne veut apporter
donc on doit tout en se disant on est
encore un sujet qui articule en raison
d'objectifs qui ont des questions très
intellectuel vous basculez et ça c'est
au niveau de la société et que ça se
décide comme aspect dans une société de
choix vous avez un certain qu'ils en
profitent c'est exactement la théorie de
houellebecq dans son mode etc selon un
ouvrage extension du domaine de la lutte
et ils montrent comment justement la
libéralisation des moeurs transforme en
quelque sorte y ait des pages assez
croustillante 2
mais comme souvent sur l'extension du
domaine de la lutte en fait la lutte
économique se transporte son transfert
dans le dans le transport désormais
souffler dans l'univers de des échanges
sexuels et il dit très justement d'un
certain qu'ils vont avoir beaucoup et
d'autres qui vont avoir très peu alors
qu'autrefois et en économie sexuelle
administrés ou est ce que je veux en
venir
je recommande cette lecture de
houellebecq est toujours d'actualité
vrai c'est aussi le fait que si vous
regardez les questions d'appauvrissement
vous rendez compte
et là il ya un bouquin de piquer ticket
très bien là dessus sur les inégalités
qui on montre voit bien que le dernier
décile c'est énormément de femmes le
même célibataire un sûr c'est à dire que
ça va créer des poches de pauvreté parce
que la liberté mais dont nous voulons
interdire le divorce jérôme quelle est
la logique qu'elle résonne comme un truc
s'appelait le socialisme à l'époque
qu'elle même un parti socialiste
expliquer justement que le libéralisme
dans toute chose n'était pas forcément
une promesse qu'il s'agit pas se leurrer
comme une règle absolument universelle
c'est pas ça du tout mais encore une
fois en quoi dépénaliser l'homosexualité
fait du tort aux hétérosexuels et aimer
et en quoi même cette dépénalisation
menace-t-elle l'ordre social
ils voient bien que nous l'aurions vient
de changer de sujet non non je sais le
voir sur une colonne et principe
mon propos était là et fera des
pénalisations valeurs là j'essaie de
vous répondre sur une question de
principe mais a ralenti à des tiers qui
s'appelle enfants merci à tous les deux
pour ce débat passionnant sur
effectivement ce qu'on peut appeler le
libéralisme culturel vont reprendre
l'expression de jérôme merci à pierre
ryan jean-marie pardon de ne pas avoir
pu citer tous vos commentaires car ils
étaient nombreux et d'une grande qualité
merci à tous et à demain
[Musique]